this is a weird question but when do you
know when it's time to walk away from a
power struggle um when you when you
almost say the words do you know who I
am okay I think when you find yourself
wanting to read the fight like
reestablish like I'm the producer I'm
the director when you find yourself
almost saying those words you should
walk away and and my philosophy has
always been that you you I don't
internalize it but i definitely look in
the mirror and say okay you're in a
situation where there's either confusion
or that you're you're being challenged
and you have to look in the mirror and
say what is it that I'm doing that is
not that that is sort of not either
giving the confidence or or the correct
direction for the for the team or is it
that you know and what is it I always
look at myself first and and I found
like if you if you work on what you're
projecting if you work on on what you
have sort of laid out to your team then
the power struggle just goes away
because ultimately those struggles are
usually just caused by people who you
know want to improve something that they
see is not working or that you haven't
given them a reason to have faith in you
you know you haven't given them enough
of an example I I like to lead by
example you know so confident so it
sounds like you're doing a gut check and
you're saying okay look someone's
challenging me am i coming across as not
confident yep is that where yeah yeah I
would say absolutely and and I like I
said it's like I feel like the the worst
thing that you could do to somebody is
be like you should respect me because i
have this title you know as opposed to
being the leader that people will
automatically look too if somebody wants
an answer and you know i work some of my
first my first jobs and features was
working as a first ad and you i became
the person that was always giving the
answers by
as a first ad you have to know
everything that's going on at all times
so once you start to see that people are
coming to you they are coming you for
answers they you know if somebody wants
to know what the next scene is or we're
going to park their car and they're
coming to you all you know to answer
those to ask those questions that shows
a level of respect and Trust so i think
when i was when i was working as an 80
you know I started to establish those
that level of trust with crew members
and with you know with directors and
with producers it's you know they don't
just look at the call sheet and
automatically respect you because you
have a job title they they look at how
your you know your work ethic and what
you're bringing every day and when
you're doing shows you know you're
working on you get a new set of people
every 30 days just about it seems like
and the only structure that sort of
keeps you all together is those
traditionally defined roles knowing what
you're doing and yeah projecting that
confidence no doubt and you know I I
always at the end of the day you know
directing is very tough because you have
to know what every single person is
doing you have to know you know what a
grip is loading into his truck you have
to know you know does the makeup artist
have to go buy new foundation you know
what what is involved if I ask for this
wardrobe you have to literally know how
everyone else does their jobs in order
to be able to communicate with them and
I think that also gives people a lot of
confidence when you know what they're
going through you know when you look at
your your wardrobe supervisor and say
look I know if I have to change this
wardrobe what it's going to do to you as
opposed to just thinking you know
magically pull it out people really
respond well to that and they'll work
harder for you if you if you if you do
that
you